you mentioned that you have a scripted
doc versus one where you followed
someone around the camera so what are
the differences but how are you
structuring side what's your point shoot
how I do documentaries which are kind of
scripted in terms of not thurs scripted
like please say this they're scripted
treatments as in well I'm going to
interview this person and I need them to
say this so that i can move on to the
story form story points of the next
scene i do very three-act structure
kinda docs and this is pretty common
like if you there's a good documentary
film on documentarians which i think is
called capturing reality not sure ah i
was shocked to see that almost all the
documentary charians on that movie which
are very highly successful
documentarians script and treatment
there documentaries so what I do is
basically kind of if I were doing an
outline or initial treatment for a
narrative film I do that for documentary
which can look very as an example say
the adultery documentary it goes from a
opening scene of adulterers talking
about adultery then we have our inciting
incident of so how did you meet this
person and then we have like our hack
turn so what happened that you know it's
it's a in a way of a movie a narrative
film but we're going to do it as a
documentary and a lot of that is just
for saving time and kind of know where
I'm going you know you can interview
somebody for hours and they can tell you
about their life and you know you don't
know where exactly it's all there and it
takes a lot of time but also its kind of
the kind of docs that I prefer is also
the reason why I do that over the just
kind of capturing someone's life I kind
of like a story when you have done them
where you just capture someone's life
and you're following them around do you
have a method
in your head of this is probably when
I'm going to try to look for first get
them talk about their child you know you
said you you do certainly cities warm up
but do you also do that when you're in
sort of freeform time give any type of
uh honestly I haven't done that in many
many years of the shooting a documentary
we're just kind of freeform I think that
that type of documentary is the
documentary where you have to follow
someone for a long time because if
you're free forming you really never
know when they're gonna save the thing
you need and then you have to kind of
edit it but you know you have to edit
while you're shooting to kind of see
where things are going um which is great
I mean obviously there's really great
documentary said that do that form uh
but for me I you know I'm not an
independently wealthy person and all
that kind of stuff where I can just stay
with some random stranger for five years
and shoot them and all that kind of jazz
you